well I'm joined from Liverpool by the
Labour MP and member of the All Party
Parliamentary Group on leasehold reform
just in matter so Justin this is great
news for people going forward but what
about the hundreds of thousands of
people who are stuck on these onerous
lease holds her and already all that the
big question isn't it
I don't anything today about the solid
plans to deal with the people would stay
on the owners some of whom are unable to
sell their properties to believe that
unless there is a clear government funds
that deal with those people and this is
the stabilized housing market now we
just been quoting the statement from
Taylor Wimpey they obviously saw the
writing on the wall and suspended
selling these sort of properties on this
terms a while ago their other house
builders out there who are still doing
it yes there's something my conspiracy
still building on at least all based and
when I've questioned them there I'm back
with anything I consider to be a
satisfactory answer but if the
government intervene and stop that
happening moving forward that's great
but as you started the piece what is it
in it what is going to happen for those
people who he's definitely donors please
we need proper funding government to
deal with those of you that have already
and the system come on there just in
name names who are these people
well you've already identified by the
wimpy is probably one of the worst
examples of owners please the anger
bubbling ground grant
certainly there are issues with the
offer that they are making because it
won't actually release people from their
least it will simply changing through an
RTI and that may mean that other forces
within the least we're not too happy
about because having fees for
permissions do engine or even a stiff
question there beholder will still be
there what we want really is a system
where people are able to buy their
freehold in a cost-effective that
inspiron on a quick way and it does we
can't but at the moment I don't think
anything we've heard today leads us to
that place I also want
perdy CLG selectivity inquire into how
this all started in the first place
because they seem to have been a
decision across the board from the
numbers as buffers do enter into this
business model which is now being shown
beyond the doubt not work in the
interest of consumers do we want to make
sure the lessons are words and this
doesn't happen again in the future
yeah this has been going on quite a
while now hasn't it no do you think the
the house builders should face
for example charges some mis-selling in
the way the banks did with ppi has it
got to that level do you think well I
had described in the past as the PPI of
the house building industry and but I
think that's why we need a strike
committee inquiry because we need these
people before the committee giving
evidence about why they made this
decision in the first place to actively
build on a second income spring for the
bodies that they were building what was
the role of the developers what was the
role of the advisors what was the role
of the landis there are huge numbers the
questions about how this all happened in
the first place because it it can't be a
coincidence so many people are now
waking up and realizing that they've
been sound of thinking that there's not
what they thought it was quite so in
other words it's possible in your eyes
that lawyers and the conveyancing sector
moving in on this racket as well then
well that's what we need to find out
I've done a survey of my constituents
who who were signed of the leasehold
properties and but 80 percent of them
told me that they didn't understand or
appreciate what it was that they were
being signed up do and I've seen some of
the leases myself they're they're very
difficult documents building standed up
in the advice that was given in some
instances was fair enough about the
implications of that you've also got to
look at where lenders have got involved
did they actually know that they were
learning money on properties that would
potentially become unsellable within a
few days up again is a big question that
needs answering all right just in
matters we're gonna leave it there
appreciate you joining me thank you